[Música]
en Estados Unidos los recientemente
elegidos representantes a la cámara y
senadores tomaron posesión de sus cargos
Ahora solo resta conocer Quién será el
nuevo presidente de la cámara de
representantes de mayoría republicana el
representante Kevin mccarthy no logró
ser elegido en la primera votación
tenemos reportes desde la ciudad de
Washington
el mundo y buena parte de Brasil
despidieron al Astro del fútbol Edson
arantes de nacimiento conocido como Pelé
ahora su cuerpo reposa en el cementerio
de la Ciudad de Santos después de un
cortejo fúnebre por las calles de la
ciudad y dos días de camara ardiente a
la que asistieron cerca de 230.000
personas
el nuevo ministro de seguridad Nacional
de Israel y tomar visitó el complejo de
las mezquitas de al Axa en Jerusalén
este una visita que provocó la condena
por parte de Palestina que advierte que
se ha cruzado una línea en este sitio
que es reservado para el culto de los
musulmanes
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González día importante para la política
en los Estados Unidos los nuevos
integrantes del Congreso elegido durante
las elecciones del medio término del
pasado mes de noviembre presentaron su
juramento y tomaron posesión de sus
cargos Lo que implica un nuevo
equilibrio y Din en la relación entre el
legislativo y el gobierno del presidente
Joe biden Ahora solo resta conocer Quién
será el presidente de la cámara de
representantes porque el republicano
Kevin mccarthy no logró ser elegido en
la primera ronda de votaciones por eso
vamos a ir hasta Washington Allí se
encuentra Cristóbal Vázquez con más
información Hola Cristóbal Muy buenas
tardes allí en la capital de Estados
Unidos y quiénes son los republicanos
que votaron en contra de Kevin mccarthy
y por qué votaron en contra de él siendo
de la misma formación política Tal
parece que ya de entrada él sabía que no
tenía los apoyos suficientes para llegar
a la presidencia de la cámara
al menos 12 al menos 12 representantes a
la cámara republicanos votaron en contra
de Kevin mccarthy Para que sea el
próximo presidente de la cámara de
representantes y sea el quien impulse
los proyectos de ley que después sean
llevados al senado y después a la
presidencia en este momento se adelanta
una segunda votación para lograr estos
218 votos que necesita Kevin mccarthy
para poder llegar a ser nombrado y
confirmado ya como presidente de la
cámara de representantes sin embargo
Pues empieza a crecer el nombre de Jim
Jordan Jim Jordan también representante
a la cámara del partido republicano está
empezando a ganar votos no tantos como
los que ya tenía Kevin mccarthy pero
pues lo suficientes para evitar que
llegue a esta cifra de 218 votos y se
pueda confirmar como presidente de la
cámara de representantes entre los que
los republicanos a destacar que están
demorando este proceso de confirmación
está Marc Gold de la Florida
la congresista de Arizona Está también
que pues es el alternativo hasta ahora
para ser presidente a la cámara de
representantes sin embargo pues eh Hay
que lograr esto 218 votos y va a ser un
una cifra muy difícil de alcanzar por
en las próximas horas en las votaciones
Cristóbal por supuesto estamos muy
atentos al resultado de esta segunda
votación que va a tomar un poco más de
tiempo pero qué pasa ahora si no se
logra elegir un presidente para la
cámara esto Qué significa para los
republicanos para esta formación que
tienen mayoría en la cámara baja
Exacto tienen mayoría en la cámara baja
además tienen una lista de proyectos de
ley que quieren avanzar y pues no se va
a poder hacer absolutamente nada para
estos proyectos de ley en este proceso
legislativo y no se puede además nombrar
absolutamente nadie ni siquiera
confirmar los a 435 representantes a la
cámara que fueron electos en las pasadas
elecciones de noviembre porque hasta que
no se confirme el presidente de la
cámara de representantes pues no se
puede hacer absolutamente nada en la en
la cámara baja muy contrario lo que pasó
en la cámara alta donde ya están
confirmados tanto líderes republicanos
como líderes demócratas Cristóbal pues
muy atentos en cualquier momento
regresamos con usted a Washington
conforme vaya avanzando esta votación y
si ya hay un resultado definitivo día
importante para la política de Estados
Unidos el día de hoy vamos a cambiar de
tema como No culpable de fraude Se
declaró el fundador de la plataforma ftx
sandback ante una corte Federal de
Manhattan Batman de 30 años es acusado
de cargos de estafa a los inversores y
también a de saquear a sus clientes de
la plataforma a través del comercio de
criptomonedas de acuerdo con la fiscalía
el hombre desvío ilegalmente su más
masivas de dinero de sus clientes para
comprar lujosos bienes raíces también
para donar dinero a políticos y para
realizar transacciones ahora el juez
entrará en conversaciones con los
abogados del acusado para determinar un
cronograma para proceder hacia un juicio
hasta la Federal
y también destacado en la jornada de hoy
Vamos hasta Brasil porque los restos de
el futbolista brasileño Edson arantes do
nacimiento conocido como Pelé ya se
encuentran en el cementerio de la Ciudad
de Santos esto después de una ceremonia
privada a la que solo asistieron sus
familiares y amigos más cercanos los
restos de ujey fueron enterrados tras un
cortejo fúnebre por las principales
calles de la ciudad en donde miles de
Seguidores se aproximaron para darle su
último adiós el cuerpo de Pelé estuvo
durante dos días en cámara ardiente
expuesto en el estadio de su equipo el
Santos a donde llegaron unas 230.000
personas entre ellas el nuevo presidente
de Brasil Luis Ignacio Luna da Silva
de parte de la familia estamos
agradecidos con todos agradecidos por
todo el amor por todo el cariño por el
respeto y bueno para expresar nuestra
gratitud el sentimiento más grande de
nuestra familia es la gratitud el de un
futbolista es la gratitud Gracias a
todos
de Brasil pasamos hasta Colombia allí
los líderes de la guerrilla del eln el
ejército de liberación nacional
desmintieron al presidente Gustavo Petro
quien aseguró que este grupo armado Era
uno de las cinco formaciones al margen
de la ley que acordaron un cese al fuego
bilateral así lo dieron a conocer de
este grupo guerrillero a través de un
comunicado que marca una Clara
diferencia entre el cese al fuego con La
tregua navideña que expiró el 2 de enero
tras el anuncio el presidente Petro
convocó a una reunión extraordinaria con
el ministro del interior el ministro de
la defensa y con delegados de la oficina
del alto comisionado para la paz el eln
sostiene en Caracas Venezuela una de
negociación en curso con el gobierno
colombiano
en otros temas la reciente visita del
ministro de seguridad de Israel y tamart
a la Explanada de las mezquitas en
Jerusalén este género tensión con las
autoridades palestinas quienes
calificaron la visita como una
provocación por tratarse de un lugar
sagrado para judíos y también para los
musulmanes Andrés Meza Muñoz tiene los
detalles en su informe
es el tercer lugar más sagrado para
musulmanes quienes lo conocen como El
noble santuario y el más sagrado para
los judíos quienes lo llaman el monte
del templo este sitio ha estado siempre
en el centro de las disputas entre
israelíes y palestinos y ahora un nuevo
motivo amenaza con avivar las tensiones
la visita del ministro de seguridad
Nacional de Israel el ultraderechista y
tamar vengavir y que autoridades
palestinas califican como una
provocación
es un desafío para los sentimientos del
pueblo palestino y hacemos un llamado a
todo nuestro pueblo que frustró el
complot que tiene como objetivo
convertir el santuario en un templo
judío y esto es una violación a todas
las normas valores acuerdos leyes
internacionales y compromisos de Israel
se paseó brevemente por la periferia del
complejo por primera vez desde que
asumió el cargo En el gabinete de
ultraderecha y según un funcionario
israelí el ministro no incumplió el
acuerdo de estatus quo heredado del
conflicto de 1967 que permite a los no
musulmanes visitar el lugar con la
condición de no desde hace tiempo
bengaví reclama un mayor acceso para los
judíos el monte del templo está abierto
para todos Sí también para judíos en el
gobierno del que soy miembro no habrá
discriminación racista y los judíos
visitarán el monte del templo en los
últimos años se ha visto un creciente
número de nacionalistas que suben a este
lugar a rezar de manera oculta en el año
2000 la visita a la Explanada del
entonces líder israelí de la oposición
el derechista Ariel Sharon fue recibida
como una provocación y al día siguiente
se produjeron sangrientos
enfrentamientos que marcaron el inicio
de la segunda intifada por vigésimo
segundo día consecutivo se mantiene el
bloqueo de activistas hacer bailanos a
la región de nagorno caravag un bloqueo
impuesto desde el pasado 12 de diciembre
el cierre del corredor de la China la
única vía de acceso terrestre a la zona
amenaza con dejar sin comida ni
medicinas a este enclave de mayoría
Armenia justamente en la República de
Armenia ha criticado la pasividad de la
comunidad internacional y de de paz
rusas por no despejar esta vía de acceso
vital para garantizar la entrada de
suministros a este territorio donde
Residen cerca de 120.000 personas
es todo en las noticias buenas tardes
[Música]